good morning Hank it's Friday today's
video is actually like Voldemort soul
because it comes to you in eight parts
it is also like the cake because it is
at least partly a lie that's right Hank
it's April Fool's Day one of these eight
parts is Allah you will either guess the
lie or I will have fooled you which will
make me the winner of an arbitrary
contest of my own creation which is my
favourite kind of game to win part one
Hank nerdfighters have done so much
research into the great and terrible
library of Ivan the Terrible that we are
now the largest resource on the entire
internet on the topic and the story
they've uncovered is crazy Hank it
involves like fireproof dungeons and
crucified skeletons and is supposedly
blind architect it's like national
treasure only it's real and the role of
Nicolas Cage is played by nerds speaking
of Nicolas Cage Hank part-2 Nicolas Cage
has a son named kal-el like the birth
name of Superman his name is kal-el
Coppola Cage because you know Nic Cage
is cousins with Sofia Coppola who by the
way made The Virgin Suicides into a
movie a book written by Jeffrey you
Jenna Diez whose facial hair may or may
not be a joke part 3 also while we're on
the topic of celebrities Michael J Fox
his middle name Andrew part 4 heck I
hate being one of those parents who
brags but Henry spoke his first multiple
word sentence this week and it was very
cute I was like hi he was like hi and I
was like hi and he was like hi and I was
like hi and then he looked me deep in
the eyes and he said hi cat part 5 I
think you probably know that marie curie
is the only person to win a nobel prize
in both chemistry and physics but did
you know that her daughter Irene also
won a Nobel Prize making her the only
Nobel Prize winner who is the mother of
a Nobel Prize winner it's a fact tank or
is it also ain't Marie Curie had a
sister named brawny Slava Sartre out
there for a bra nice Lola hey this is
off-topic but I will pay you one
American dollar if you write a song
about Marie Curie sister called it's
hard out there for a bra nice la la
parts a tank you may remember that I
purchased Warner Chilcott stock after
Warner Chilcott Warner choked out of you
and other people with ulcerative colitis
well heck I sold that stock today for a
$26 profit I'm on a roller coaster that
only goes up baby hey guy don't think
I've ever felt worse about making $26
I'd like to use that money to decrease
worldsuck preferably in a way that
Warner Chilcott swoon or choke on
nerdfighters if you have any ideas leave
them in comments part 7 Hank people say
my fear of heights is irrational but you
know what's the most common cause of
non-fatal emergency room visits between
the ages of 25 and 30 for unintentional
fall
Heights are the most common cause of
unintentional Falls meaning that high
throw the greatest non-fatal problem
facing members of our generation so Hank
let that be a lesson to you do not put
yourself in a situation where you could
fall unintentionally part eight Hank
even though you're like successful and
grown up and everything do you know that
if you google image search your name
this is the second result so that's it
seven truths in one line nerdfighters
leave your guests in comments I hope you
don't get fooled Hank you're a tomato
I'll see you on Monday PS nerdfighters
if you haven't seen Hanks video about
the ice cream cords your mind is about
to be blown click anywhere on the screen
and find out why Rebecca Black and
Slipknot have some surprising things in
common